okay let's talk a little bit about
backgrounds again but this time we'll
see how you can digitally change the
background now if you remember from
previous tutorials we discussed
collecting interesting backgrounds to
use while making the images whether
you're working with a flatbed scanner or
camera but sometimes we're in a bit of a
rush as I was while making this initial
image of these two paper devices at the
time I didn't think about enhancing the
image by including an interesting
background maybe to pop out the devices
visually so after I made the image on
the flatbed scanner this is what we got
and as we zoom in we see a problem a bit
of a mess with all sorts of stuff all
over it that's the price I pay for being
in a hurry and not cleaning the glass
that day hint hint so because of the
presence of all of this extraneous
material we can't simply select the
background with let's say the magic wand
and fill in that selected area with a
color the algorithm for that selection
tool will not select the dirty spots and
the Paint Bucket won't do that either
you see here that the paint bucket
filling the background will not fill in
the dirty bits either so that's not
going to work let's undo that with
command Z so what I'm going to wind up
doing if I want to change this
background is to do it in a different
way let me show you how we're going to
try okay i'll use the polygonum lasso
and I'll enlarge this again move it over
and watch I select what is initially
going to be selecting just the two
devices this will take a bit so we can
speak
up the video a little bit not to bore
you too much although a little boredom
is good for the soul okay I'm getting
there almost there okay here we go so
what's going on is that I selected in
fact actually a couple of things if you
really think about it yes I selected the
devices but if you go to the inverse of
the selection that means it will invert
the selection to everything other than
the devices which means the full
background now that I am completely
selecting the full background I'm going
to fill it with the color that I
previously selected it's shown as the
foreground color add a hundred percent
and here we go and the background is
filled now I want to show you a little
extra which i think is worth thinking
about I'm going to once again go to the
selection menu and invert the selection
once again so that we are in fact back
to selecting the devices I'm going to
open up the layers window because i'm
going to show you that we're working
just at this point with one layer okay
here we go here's the layers window so
remember i first selected this inverted
the selection which selected the
background and inverted it back again to
select the devices so we are back to
selecting the devices i'm now going to
make a layer of these devices by copying
it that's command C which has just
copied the selected devices and then
command V which has pasted what I just
copied creating basically another layer
of just the devices you can't see that
because the copy layer is identical to
the devices in the original background
image now what I'm going to do is
something I
thing is fun and and I think helpful to
the image I'm going to go to layers then
layer style now remember we're talking
about what is labeled here as layer 1
i'm going to create a drop shadow which
i like you can play around with the
various qualities like angle of the
shadow distance of the shadow the spread
the size but watch as I change these
particular characteristics what you're
seeing here is a drop shadow ok I'm
going to say ok and I'm going to zoom in
a little bit to show you what we've done
created the shadow in that layer only
I'm going to make this new layer
invisible to show you the difference
here's how the background the original
image looks on its own and here it is
with the drop shadow so for me it this
looks a little bit more like the initial
image with its own shadows on the
flatbed one more thing I'm going to
convert the image into a more horizontal
image sometimes you want to add more
space either making it more vertical or
horizontal to fit a certain format so
the color with which we want to extend
the image is this color that needs to be
in the background box when we increase
canvas size ok I'm going to go to the
image canvas size and here I think this
might work and if it doesn't we can add
a little more to change the width making
the image longer let's just go let's
make it 15 so the algorithm will divide
the additional five inches on both sides
of the image keeping in mind that the
original image is placed in the center
of that process and here is the revamped
image it gives us a little more space on
both sides so the last thing I'm going
to show you is just a little bit of
labeling so
like to insert a label indicating that
this area from here to there is a
centimeter but before we do that we
still have two layers so let's flatten
the image so there we're only working
with one layer as you see there's only
one in the window now I'm going to take
our line trying it in white you can try
it in black or whatever color you want
okay that's not bad let me undo this
that's command Z I want the lines to be
a little closer to the area that I'm
connecting it to there's one here's
another it's okay we're going to add
some text which i think i'm also going
to make in white and I'm going to label
it let's say one centimeter and mmm
that's too small let's see it's 18 using
your style let's go to 24 points and see
how that looks almost there I'll go back
to move it a little bit um that should
do it yep I like it
you